the fresh prince of bel air is one of
the 90s most iconic sitcoms
unfortunately for every great episode
there is one that doesn't quite hit the
mark
from the funniest highs to the cringiest
lows these are the best and worst
episodes of the fresh prince of bel air
i icloudness is a truly cringe-worthy
episode that doesn't really fit in with
the vibe of the series at all
while other episodes manage to combine
serious life-threatening scenarios with
smith's signature brand of humor this
one just doesn't work
the premise is that uncle phil is
presiding over a high-profile trial
and is getting some threatening messages
as a result so when he
will and carlton stop at a gas station
and are suddenly held up by a clown with
a bomb strapped to him
things get serious but not at all
humorous
the crazed mad clown wants his big break
via a tv appearance
but the whole thing is really just kind
of sad the clown isn't funny
his performance is pathetic and having
uncle phil will
and carlton mock him just makes them
seem mean sure
they're being held up and threatened but
mockery isn't exactly a good angle to
take when you're trying to talk down
somebody who's on the edge all in all
this was one of those
season six episodes where it felt like
as the series was wrapping up
they had really begun to run out of
ideas
in the first season of fresh prince
carlton gets a lesson in what will's
life is really like
the bank's family are heading to palm
springs to visit friends when uncle
phil's business partner asks carlton to
drive his mercedes
since everyone else is going via
helicopter will tags along
but the two are soon pulled over and
arrested carlton believes the official
story that they were pulled over for
driving too
slowly and arrested because the car
wasn't theirs
but carlton's world view was crushed
when will insists they were only being
pulled over because they were two black
guys spotted driving a nice car
uncle phil bails them out but not
without giving the cops a warranted
lecture on their legal mishandling of
the situation
when will carlton and uncle phil get
back home will berate carlton for
believing that their race had nothing to
do with the incident
i hope you like that system because you
won't be seeing a whole lot of it during
your lifetime
in the end carlton appeals to his dad
who wants nothing less than to destroy
his son's innocence with the realities
of racial profiling in the criminal
justice system
if any of the more serious episodes of
fresh friends are still relevant today
it's this one mistaken identity sadly is
a genuinely timeless classic i don't
want to marry you
see
that wasn't that hard was it
it was only a matter of time before
playboy will found a serious girlfriend
but settling into marriage while barely
through college that's where this
particular relationship
lost the love of a lot of fans lisa was
introduced during the early part of
season 5
in will's misery the premise of that
episode was that lisa was pledging a
sorority and had to capture the
notorious womanizer will for some misery
style shenanigans
that storyline already put some people
off to the character to begin with
so when the two ended up engaged less
than a season later
things still didn't feel right in a
decent proposal
will finds himself healing in the
hospital after being shot by a mugger
he's probably under the influence of
painkillers and definitely high on the
adrenaline of his near-death experience
so naturally that's when he proposes to
lisa lisa will you marry me
lisa later confronts will and says he
only proposed to her because he
experienced a moment of vulnerability
well getting shot kind of has that
effect on her brother
eventually the two go through counseling
and end up not going through with the
wedding after all
but the whole relationship made an
otherwise top-notch season kind of a
downer
as for lisa she sadly didn't have a
personality
other than being will's girlfriend so
she quickly disappeared
without a second thought throughout the
entire run of fresh prince
will always aspired to be some sort of
ladies man
he was constantly hitting on girls
taking them on dates and trying to get
them alone
in later seasons he finally devoted
himself to lisa
but not without solidifying his
reputation as a total player
so when will actually hit it off with a
girl who was unlike any of the others
he's dated
the show managed to tackle the issue of
body shaming and sizeism long before
those words ever became a thing in
society
season 2's she ain't heavy features
queen latifah as didi
will's blind date to a basketball game
who's a little more plus-sized than he's
used to
but dede calls him on a snap judgment of
her size and the two really bond over
their shared sense of humor in similar
interests
will's still too afraid to ask dede to
the school dance however
knowing that his friends have already
made fun of him for hanging with her
that's right i can't figure out how
brother goes from t-bone rump rose
that's
ultimately will and dede go on other
dates but they both have a miserable
time
will recognizes the error of his ways
and the two make up
unfortunately the relationship was soon
forgotten as is the way of episodic
sitcoms
but didi's storyline really brought a
breath of fresh air to fresh prince
in the incredibly offensive episode get
a job will
and carlton both battle it out for the
position as an assistant on hillary's
daytime talk show
in order to get the gig will lands a
famous movie director named maurice
played by chris rock but maurice says
that he'll only appear on hillary's show
if will takes his sister
jasmine for a date night out on the town
the sister turns out to be chris rock
and drag
and she totally digs will who has to
fake liking her to show her a good time
looking back now the whole thing comes
off as incredibly transphobic
and the cross-dressing comedy is pretty
out of date and not at all funny
from the leopard print dress to the bad
platinum blonde wig to the bright red
lipstick
it's clear that the whole role of
jasmine is supposed to be a character of
a drag queen
which by today's standards is more than
a little insensitive
this was another late series episode
with the only plus side being that
rock's career took
off after the appearance in blood is
thicker than mud
will and carlton participate in rush
week at college and decide to pledge
phi beta gamma a black fraternity on
campus like any other frat rush
the tasks are humiliating and grueling
but carlton is definitely treated the
worst by top dog the leader of the frat
because of his rich background so when
will makes phi beta gamma but carlton
doesn't
will tries to pretend that neither of
them made it however when carlton
eventually confronts top dog
the frat leader calls carlton a sellout
i'm not accepting no prep school bella
bread sell out into my fraternity
but carlton surprisingly enough stands
up for himself
being black isn't what i'm trying to be
it's what i am
i'm running the same race and jumping
the same hurdles you are so why are you
tripping me up
when will and carlton get home uncle
phil expresses his sympathy
in a truly heartbreaking way when are we
going to stop doing this to each other
the episode did a wonderful job of
showing just how complex carlton
banks is as a character as a young black
man going to prestigious schools and
living among affluence and wealth
he's constantly called on to prove that
he belongs in the world of the wealthy
elite
yet on the other end of the spectrum his
blackness is constantly called into
question because of that affluence
and his cultural identity is questioned
by other black people because of his
wealthy upbringing
it must have been a pretty strange way
to have grown up and as this episode
proves
there's far more to carlton than tom
jones and sweater vests
clip shows are almost always boring and
the fresh prince of bel-air had a good
handful of them during its sixth season
run
by far the worst however was during
season four
in for sale by owner when the banksizer
offered one million dollars to sell
their home to a wealthy anonymous buyer
the episode then revisits some of the
bank's most cherished items in their
home
with only ashley wanting to stay put the
rest of the family is chomping at the
bit for a big payday
in the end though they're out of luck
the anonymous
buyer turns out to be donald trump and
his then-wife marla maples
as it turns out however trump was
actually talking about the house next
door to the banks
so the deal is off the big 4-0 really
showcases the comedy and confidence that
all of the characters exuded throughout
the show's run
especially when it comes to aunt viv
facing the reality of turning 40 years
old
aunt viv starts having a bit of a
midlife crisis when her kids play her a
video at her birthday party showing some
old home movies and photos
she remembers that at one point in her
life all she wanted to do was dance
so aunt viv decides to head to a dance
class and also
audition for a major role the other
younger dancers in the group
question her abilities but aunt viv
proves them all wrong
she blows the other dancers out of the
water in an amazing performance
driven by janet hubert witten who was
originally a broadway star herself
once she's done she gives the mocking
dancers a snap before proudly leaving
the room
as a result aunt viv is offered one of
the lead roles but she turns it down
devoting herself to her job as a college
professor and her family
she just wanted to know that she could
still do it if she wanted to and boy
does she prove it without a doubt the
very worst episode of the fresh prince
of bel-air is the one where will
lies to a girl and fakes their wedding
just to have sex with her and take her
virginity
yes you heard that right this was a new
low not just for fresh prince
but for tv sitcoms in general here's how
it goes down
will's girlfriend monique tells him that
she's saving herself for marriage
so what does will do rather than respect
her wishes and self-confidence
he proposes to her and of course monique
for some reason says yes
and will has jazz officiate a fake
wedding will even gets
all the way to their wedding night hotel
room before he finally comes clean
and doesn't let monique go through with
it watching the episode now
will's behavior is such a serious act of
deviant mistrust that is practically
criminal will's actions are so
disgusting disrespectful and vile that
the episode is genuinely hard to watch
after will's dad lou abandoned him and
his mother when will was just a little
kid
will grew up without a father figure in
his life so when lou returns after 14
years
will is simultaneously hesitant and
excited when his dad tells him he's
finally ready to be part of his life
it's too little too late but will
forgives his dad
much to the distress of uncle phil who
can't forgive lou for abandoning his
family
lou and will start planning a
summer-long road trip together but when
the time to leave rolls around
lou refuses to commit yet again and
tries to bail without even saying
goodbye to will
thankfully uncle phil catches him and
makes him face will himself
some business came up i gotta handle so
we're gonna have to put a
our trip on hold you understand
once lou is gone however will breaks
down in a mixture of anger and sadness
how come he don't want me man that's
when he collapses
crying into the arms of the only man
who's ever been a father figure to him
the episode proved not only that smith
could really act when the drama called
for it
but the show wasn't afraid to tackle
serious issues like absentee fathers and
psychological trauma
the episode was funny touching sad and
filled with love
in other words it was fresh prince of
bel air at its very best
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one